what does the fictional drug drops do
exactly is it new to the batman mythos
and how will it play into the penguin's
criminal ambitions keep watching for
what we know and where we think things
might go warning spoilers for the batman
head the gotham city that director matt
reeves brings to life in the batman is a
place where corrupt politicians and law
enforcement work hand in dirty hand with
the real rulers of the town who live
outside the law and pay enough to keep
it that way from gang wars to money
laundering it's a challenging place to
keep in check things only get stranger
when the mayor gets killed by a creepy
criminal mastermind who loves riddles
and the only reliable figure in town is
struggling to be taken seriously because
he dresses like a bat i'm vengeance the
gotham of the batman also has a serious
drug problem this new drug on the
streets referred to as drops is
impacting every rung of the social
ladder but just what are these so-called
drops though there are some fictional
drugs that pop up in the comics and
other media drops don't appear in the
more than eight decades of batman's
history this is a new fictional drug
devised by reeves and co-writer peter
craig presented within the first few
minutes of the new film
applied by the user like a simple eye
drop the drug causes hyperactivity and
paranoia as shown by district attorney
gil coulson when he's speaking to selena
at 44 below the substance's impact on
the city continues throughout the film
it's a festering issue bubbling
underneath batman's greater challenge of
battling the riddler and uncovering the
corruption that permeates a city from
penguin's thwarted distribution scheme
to batman and gordon encountering
so-called dropheads holing up in the
abandoned orphanage batman's war on
drops in gotham continues to rage on
even after he's called a hero for now
there aren't any answers about this
drug's future however a future spin-off
series on hbo max about the penguin may
just provide new answers when last we
see him colin farrell's oswald cobblepot
aka the penguin is looking at a flooded
gotham city and seeing a new dawn with a
wide open space for a new crime boss to
take over carmine falcone's former
empire
it stands to reason then that the
penguin spin-off will focus on precisely
that as cobblepop fights his way to the
top of the criminal empire eventually
reaching his inevitable archvillain
status the crime boss has got to make
money somehow and chances are that drops
will continue to be a crucial part of
his operation still a business like this
is tough with the competition even more
so it's a safe bet that mr cobblepot
could have a gang war on the horizon
speaking to hero nation reeves revealed
that the upcoming show will take
inspiration from the likes of machine
gun toting gangster gem scarface and
british crime classic the long good
friday both films saw their lead
character at the top of their
organizations forced to go head-on with
competition with unpleasant results for
to my new both
the series is likely to see the penguin
make new enemies a kind that don't have
pointy bad ears perhaps a form of
competition could arise in the form of
another drug namely could the drug venom
be making its way into the world of the
batman and with it its most famous user
bane
many fans theorize that the green liquid
batman pumped himself with to save
selena was venom the go-to drug used by
bane in the comics to increase his
strength while it hasn't been confirmed
whether this was the mysterious green
goo or it was simply a shot of
adrenaline seeing venom enter the world
of the batman could lead to some
exciting conflict perhaps this version
of bane would be a little closer to the
comics than the tom hardy incarnation in
the dark knight rises could the penguins
hbo max spin-off see cobblepot's
operation get muscled over by bane in
the process could we find out the
origins of drops and their manufacturer
after all we never did find out what the
character who is now confirmed to be the
joker was an arkham form the arrival of
venom some other new drug or competing
crime bosses could definitely spell
trouble for cobblepot's now flooded
empire
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]